So Below you want to have a baby now
yeah I I started buying baby stuff
clothes and and try to you want to put
off having a baby listen Shada explains
why she doesn't want to have a baby with
Bilal now after she gave him that
ultimatum that if they don't try to have
a baby within nine months she's
gone
plus one of below's best friends joins
the show and goes head to head with
shaida's best friend utris in certain
instances especially in those that
regarding your husband
why are you talking to somebody who
doesn't even have one
girl the shade the shade of it all for
you Tris it was rough for her but
thankfully things end on a beautiful
note shaida and happy tears this is all
the other one did us there this was a
great episode let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia before
we get into Bilal and shaida we have to
talk about a few other must-see moments
from part three of the tell-all y'all
Jenny and Big Ed get into it and while I
don't wish drama for anyone I could
watch these two argue for hours it's
pure comedy here's a little background
before I show you how it all went down
Big Ed has been receiving a lot of
backlash from the cast due to his
behavior toward Liz on the tell-all to
sum it up he's lied to everyone and then
when they pull out receipts he creates
another lie or all of a sudden he has
Amnesia I don't remember
at one point when he gets caught in a
lie he asked Liz to give him her
engagement ring back on camera let me
have my ring back oh
wow wow
oh wow which was extremely distasteful
but what ultimately doesn't make sense
is that Liz keeps coming back it's like
she's addicted to the extreme highs and
lows of this toxic relationship the day
after Ed asked for the engagement ring
back she came into the studio with
another ring on oh I fell naked without
my ring so I oh you put on something and
I just filled up I just feel weird
without it so it's just like oh you're
serious weird yeah
now Liz
one part of me is like girl you need to
take responsibility for yourself and
snap out of it
then the other side kind of feels bad
for her because she seems to be so used
to unstable relationships that she keeps
herself in them because they feel normal
the Liz you've never been alone you've
always been with a guy you've always
been in toxic sick relationships based
off of my research over the years if
chaos is all you're used to in a
relationship your mind and your body can
become addicted to those emotions and
just like any bad habit it can be hard
to break the cycle but Liz it's time to
muscle up the strength and quit this one
because like Jenny is about to tell Ed
it's ridiculous
let's get into that argument the problem
was is denial about racism you can't
move on and they bring in you don't have
forgiveness as the cast is backstage Liz
and Ed start going back and forth about
the same thing him lying and her not
forgiving him for his lies Liz then
storms off that's when Jenny butts in
well look look she can't even have a
conversation well she's hurt she's not
gonna be us but you're just taking her
side and that's not helping the
relationship is weird it doesn't make
any sense yeah Jenny so is yours come on
first of all I'll deny to this day that
I was in a dating app
trying to tell you why is
[Applause]
that what you said was very rude what
did I say but you how you responded to
me like oh I don't get their
relationship like you know you don't
belittle me and my relationship next
Jovi steps in and tells Ed to watch how
he's talking to Jenny be polite she
didn't say anything wrong
this way Adam I'm not the only one well
speak your mind but I am right you were
being rude to me and I'm just telling
you that that's all I'm saying how you
responded to me right but the way you
said it was rude I'm sorry okay
man this dude is like you guys where did
you find this guy
uh India uh hell no they wouldn't even
give you a Visa
Jenny From the Block came out and I love
it that was such a great comeback you
guys where did you find this guy
uh India uh hell no they wouldn't even
give you a Visa all right moving on to
another moment I want to update you on
Osman and Kim we are not together not
together no honestly love Kim Ali
but there are certain teens
we try to work on it and it didn't work
out so we just have to give it up to cut
straight to the chase Usman gets all the
Heat this episode which in my opinion
is well deserved I hope everyone sees
them for what he is you know what I'm
saying selfish narcissistic and really
needs to get it together for real Kim
San Jamal joins the cast on stage and
makes a lot of sound points when it
comes to usman's behavior toward his mom
I think his intention with my mom were
like
selfish and narcissistic because it's
like you put her in a position
where obviously you knew she was already
head over heels for you before you're in
a relationship calling your potential
and all that bull so it's like you knew
that you had her
and you worked her and broke her down
and broke her into pieces which I said I
was gonna have to fix you're not talking
about that I am not the one who cannot
keep the child hey us man Usman Usman
please stop over talking me
oh okay Jamal goes on to say that Usman
used Kim to stay relevant which
makes a lot of sense I applied to be on
TV because I love being on TV and the
majority if not all the cast agrees with
Jamal's takes I think we spend Loki
played out of my mom the cast also
agrees that Usman is not in love with
Kim he might love her as a friend but
he's not in love with her which leads
Usman to come up with this BS argument
that you can even take seriously
Kimberly I love you to that I think you
are in denial yep I think Usman he loves
you like a friend and he cares for you
but he's not in love with you you are in
love with him but we have sex
with somebody
he's trying to play all of us now it was
when she never forced you into this
relationship like you could always say
no and chose to be with someone else yep
but you chose to be in it
it's not making sense to me you're not
checking out about that I do not break
up she break home
we fight but when we fight didn't I give
you the care you want Kimberly we fine
but I always tell you slowly even if I
am wrong or not
I stood by you before my family
the way it's looking us man you stood by
wanting to be on TV and wanting to be
famous before your family
Sean goes on to ask him if there is any
chance of her rekindling things with
Usman and her response just shows how
good of a heart she has no
at this time I'm just going to wish him
well I love him and I always support him
I always support his music I'll always
be super fan she is better than me
anything Soulja Boy would be in the
trash delete delete we'll see what
happens later on
that night walk out of this door today
and meet the man of my dreams yeah okay
but I will say I get I love him
this is just really hard take a breath
it's just it's really really hard the
segment ends with Jamal walking up to
his mom while she's in tears and
Whispering this sweet message to her
okay
you'll be okay so Mom we want to thank
you so much thank you Sean always good
to see you good to see you again thank
you we know you only want what's best
for your mom one thing that can feel
worse than getting hurt is hurting
another person usman's definitely done
some damage here and hopefully this
teaches him that this is not the Usman
show you're dealing with people's real
emotions here that affect their lives if
I had to empathize with him just a bit I
will say I know from experience
sometimes you meet a great person who is
into you romantically and you might not
be into them that way but because
they're so wonderful you develop love
for them and you end up not wanting to
lose them you also think to yourself wow
they're so great I should want to be
with this person I'll admit it can be a
complicated place to be in but to
Jamal's point you can't be selfish if
you really care about them you have to
let that person go so they can find
someone who can give them what they
truly desire it might hurt their
feelings momentarily but at least they
won't lose respect for you you're doing
the right thing speaking of doing the
right thing below made things things
right with his wife shy to this episode
but before we get into his romantic
gesture let's talk about the drama that
led up to it shaida you gay falal a nine
month ultimatum to start having a family
where are you on that timeline we
learned that Bilal is now ready to have
a baby with shaida after telling her for
months that he wanted to wait a year or
two even though she's almost 40. Bilal
what made you have this turnaround
you know obviously she's somebody who I
want to be for the rest of my life and I
I seen how emotional she was
um and she's not a a crier usually but I
just you know put all that to
perspective obviously what the doctor
said and I was like you know let's go
ahead and do it well now that Bilal has
had a change of heart at the top of this
week's episode after all the stress and
tears Shadow reveals that she no longer
wants to have a baby right now and she
explains why I've decided to focus on on
my business and grounding myself in
America
I feel like I'm finally finding myself I
cannot I am finally finding myself and
it feels amazing like I want children
yes just not immediately right right now
maybe you want it because he said no the
Sarah's women are and then he says okay
then you're like I got my way am I right
seriously by the way this episode with
the spotlight not being on Angela she
was super cool giving good advice and
Good Vibes anyway back to shaida after
she gave that first explanation I I am
the one who normally tells him to wrap
it up I tell him because she has up she
goes on to reveal the other reasons why
she's now hesitant to have a child with
Bilal and they have to do with trust
Bilal shares that every time he gives
shaida money is gone very quickly
basically it sounds like he doesn't
trust her ability to manage money yet
do you know how much Bilal makes a year
I don't have a clue what anything yeah
that's wild for me that's information I
gather while dating someone when things
get serious of course if I'm thinking
about building with you I need to know
where we both stand y'all do you know
how much money Joby makes yeah of course
I do I know how much he spent
I don't see a problem with opening a
bank account it's very easy we have
multiple accounts but they're all joined
really everything yeah when it comes to
what the money situation has to do with
shaida having a baby she tells Sean or
should I say yard tells Sean on Shadow's
behalf that she doesn't feel comfortable
having a baby with Bilal because he
doesn't trust her and in my opinion it's
probably also because Shadow doesn't
trust him they're married and she
doesn't even know how much money he
makes I could imagine that's scary so
you don't trust her to be smart it's not
that I don't trust is that I want to
teach her but when I'm trying to teach
her then I'm lecturing shadow goes on to
reveal that Bilal can be a bit cheap
take her example from their movie dates
you don't even want to buy popcorn
that's that's true I'm not going yeah
to buy popcorn at the movie
we we'll go to the gas station
look it's not my place to talk about how
Bilal chooses to manage his finances I
know a lot of people who choose to spend
money on the Necessities their
appearance in their home but they choose
to save when it comes to frivolous items
like popcorn at the movies at the same
time I can see how it below's
thriftiness plus not knowing how much
money he makes or having access to his
account can cause shaida to be nervous
there are a lot of Secrets here and a
lack of trust on both sides it's like if
you got money while we can't buy popcorn
that would be my first thought but like
I said there are some people who operate
like that when it boils down to it I
believe that Bilal loves shaida I think
he wants the best for her but I'm not
sure if he sees her as an equal you're
being cautious of money and you're
teaching her to be cautious why you need
to teach her she's what 15 years old she
is a grown-ass woman and she planning to
open her business and bring bread to the
table
here's the thing here's the thing with
that
um I don't know like why does it feel
like just because a person is an adult
that you can't learn something but if I
teach it to her then I'm mansplaining
again bilal's close friend Chris joins
the tell-all and gives his take on
blau's mansplaining if it's a situation
that she's I'm familiar with or he feels
like he can you know direct her with the
right set of information then why not
try to give her you know the best the
best chance to win Kim was not hearing
that now this is the one that really
starts to get juicy Shadow spring utrish
joins the tell-all and immediately the
energy between she and Chris becomes
very tense I still think basically that
you know below Michael managers a lot
and that he's not really like
transparent in a lot of things
what man doesn't want to lead his family
whatever monitoring he's doing to make
it sound like that's a bad thing I think
that's a mischaracterization of them
completely oh absolutely whatever she
wants she gets my friend utris goes on
to say that shaida is willing to learn
from Bilal but the way below goes about
teaching her is the problem
has already done quite a bit in his life
he's had children he's got a wife who's
had businesses he's done so many things
it's like nobody takes his perspective
into an actual account it's like
everything needs to be revolved around
the woman and that's not fair to him
doesn't matter if we're not going to
look at this from an equitable position
and all we're doing is having a distance
continuous conversation about feelings
he's a smart guy big Ed just heard big
words
Chris is making a solid point though we
have to look at both sides I get that
Sean then brings up Shada and uterus's
conversation in New York what if he
accidentally
when uterus suggested that she stopped
taking her birth control and essentially
tricked below into having a baby uh I
don't I don't think that was cool yeah
Delilah of course I'm gonna touch out of
that China wants to have a child and as
far as you're concerned you have your
two kids already you have your wife and
you're happy and living your life who
said I don't want to have more children
though no one would in their right mind
ever give a friend that kind of advice
that is you don't play you don't play
around with pregnancy bringing a life
into this world does some serious stuff
you know what I mean I think that was a
little shady to say
in certain instances especially in those
that regarding your husband
why are you talking to somebody who
doesn't even have one oh
look at shaida's face I know it's not
her fault but if I was her I would be
thinking oh sorry friend sorry I brought
you on this show
I'm sorry
I'm sorry it's me Chris first of all let
me put you
I'm sorry to tell you
tricking your husband into having a
child yeah well are you out there
drinking man and just having children
off of school are you doing that you
just said I'm turning the other cheek
Chris this is what I'm gonna say to you
you speak very carelessly I speak very
directly because I want to be understood
Sean asks you Tris if she regrets giving
shot of that birth control advice and
she says she was just trying to look out
for her friend how are you here for
Schneider if you're trying to get her to
sabotage her relationship you want her
to be single like um Chris go easy on
her
with sabotage his marriage all on his
own I don't need to do anything try to
make a loud relationship will work
because Shadow is that type of person to
make it work however I do not want to
try to do that with the expense of her
happiness well Shadow responded to that
by saying she is happy expensive your
happiness I'm happy which put uterus in
an even more awkward position
yeah after all that back and forth shot
at Shadow one last time if she still
wants to hold off on the baby
yeah but then below pulls a move that
changes everything when I think of New
York I don't want us to think about that
you know I'd rather for us to think
about something better
what's that you know
so
I want to ask you
would you have my baby will you want to
go half on a baby
oh
if you think I'm cute you should see my
mommy oh my God is that a is that a yes
Shadow and tears says yes and once they
sit down she tells Bilal that this is
all she ever wanted
so
does this change the timeline at all for
you
I think so
I think so
what a long way you guys came wow you
know
Shadow you're really emotional right now
what are you thinking
I just hope I'll be able to film them
and not have to do it too
oh you'll be the best mama
I mean amazing
yes
I always wanted
Christopher is a wonderful middle name
by the way
the cast loves Chris
and when it comes to starting to try for
that baby below and Shadow said
immediately it says New York on it so
absolutely
now while this was super sweet and
romantic I can't help but wonder if the
money issues are out of the window I'm
still a little confused but maybe shot
as explanations for not wanting to have
a baby were just a cover-up to a deeper
fear of not being able to conceive
I just hope I'll be able to fear mom and
then I'll do it too maybe
either way I'm glad these two found
common ground and hopefully sometime
soon or at the right time we will get
some pregnancy news from shy and Below
next week is the fourth and final part
of the tell-all and from the looks of
the preview Jenny and Ed get into it
again you're a crybaby you have insulted
everybody what the hell is so perfect
about you stop it you had your turn
yesterday it's not about you you had
your turn whenever I want to take my
turn my turn is not when you tell me to
you better tell him Jenny all right 90
day fans fam make sure you stick with ET
because we are covering it all I will
see you next time
[Music]
foreign